60% of Americans are in favor of a third
party I have an idea for a third party
that party should be an all trans party
because then that will start a
conversation should trans politicians be
allowed to vote with CIS politicians is
there an unfair Advantage there because
their bone density is
bigger we do need another party how
about we get a new party with RFK and
Tulsi Gabbert called we swear to God
we're not Republicans let's go
libertarian no safety nets all charity
let's depend on the selfish Goodwill of
humanity and see how La Fair capitalism
does are people greedy is it inevitable
that we'll have to bail out the economy
with redistributed taxes from the people
we should set up on two sides of the
country and see which one does better
and make it a show film it the right
side of the country all Democrat the
left side of the country all Republican
and see who's doing better and then at
that point you just got to be quiet
after whoever wins wins and don't be a
sore loser